bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors 400 qu'actif a
réclamé par les talibans sont sur le
point d'être libéré le président s'il
refusait jusque là
pourquoi changer d'avis maintenant
difficile refusé c'était un obstacle
effectivement dans le majeur pour la
poursuite des négociations intra afghane
parce que il y avait une interrogation
sur le profil en fait de ces 400 dernier
libérable en réalité dans le dans la
corde de fin février avec entre les
américains et les talibans il y avait
l'idée de d'élargir 5000 taliban d'un
côté un millier de soldats prisonniers
de l'autre mais l'essentiel avait été
fait mais il ya eu effectivement un
blocage sur ces 400 avec un profil un
peu particulier qui restait à une pierre
d'achoppement
parce qu'il y avait une partie a été
d'ailleurs condamné à mort pour homicide
ou enlèvement pour viol donc un profil
de criminels plus que d'insurgés or il
se trouve que ça faisait partie d'une
demande explicite des talibans qui
manifestement accepté de monnayer les
noms auprès des familles
et puis parmi ses 400 il y avait 44 10
indésirables qui avait participé à des
attentats notamment contre les soldats
français dans la kapisa où contrôle
interne l'intercontinental en 2018 donc
c'était vraiment un problème majeur et
c'est pas étonnant que le président ait
préféré passer par l'option de line loya
jirga grande assemblée pour pouvoir
d'une certaine manière ne pas assumer
seul ce choix les pourparlers vont
pouvoir comment faire là oui c'est ce
que c'est ce qu'a dit aujourd'hui le
porte parole des taliban soit chahine en
disant qu'effectivement dans la semaine
à venir le dernier obstacle avait été
levée à partir du moment où les
libérations deviendra effective dans le
prolongement d'un décret présidentiel du
président ashraf ghani
il y avait plus d'obstacle majeur pour
effectivement débuté cette 3e étape
jugée essentielle pour l'afghanistan et
surtout pour les américains qui
souhaitent se désengager le plus
rapidement possible alors que va
demander chaque camp une fois qu'ils
seront installés autour de la table des
pourparlers
ça c'est tout le problème effectivement
de la situation post départ américain
c'est pas le souci premier des états
unis puisque en faisant référence à la
libération de ces 400 profil particulier
mike pompéo avait dit que c'était une
mesure difficile impopulaire mais qui
foulait là qu'il fallait la prendre
donc l'objectif des américains surtout
vu les difficultés intérieures de donald
trump dans la perspective de la
présidentielle de novembre
c'est de parvenir à remplir cette
promesse présidentielle qui était le
retrait intégral un des 2 à 2 et les
milliers de soldats américains qui
demeurait sur l'argument est donc
évidemment cette ultime phase de
négociation intra afghane est
susceptible de conforter la stratégie
américaine de désengagement justement le
désengagement américain il ya quelques
troupes qui sont déjà partis
désengagement total prévu l année
prochaine est ce que c'est pas un peu
prématuré on a du mal à imaginer l'armée
a de galles seul pour contenir la
sécurité dans le pays
oui c'est tout le problème est
d'ailleurs c'était un moyen de pression
sur le président sera fera ni pour
négocier et accepter le justement de
cette option sur les 400 derniers
prisonniers à libérer parce que il y
avait la menace d'un retrait encore plus
accélérée de la part de l'administration
trup ceux de ce que ne peut pas se
permettre effectivement le gouvernement
afghan qui va se retrouver seul avec
comme interlocuteur des insurgés qui
sont en position de force dans dans
beaucoup d'endroits du pays et donc il
ya un vrai point d'interrogation sur la
suite effectivement parce que sur le
fond les talibans n'ont pas changé de
registre concernant la nature du régime
islamique qui aurait vocation à se
mettre en place
après une transition et on verra
justement le poids des uns et des autres
par rapport à cette réalité post autre
américain david rigoulet roze merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur spécialiste du moyen-orient
rédacteur en chef de la revue aurions
stratégique merci